Yeah.
Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and I am
just checking in on you everybody.
Um,
Oh God, I don't know any
other way to fucking say it.
I'm just going to have a recording
of it. Um, yeah, just checking on.
You look at you guys. It's
already Thursday. Thursday
is over. Tomorrow's Friday.
And then it's just a one way ticket
to fuck town. What do you care?
Quite as fucking weekend
of the year right here.
They'd be getting of the NFL season.
College football is already in
full fucking full gear for bold,
full speed.
I don't what the fuck you say.
I watched another a college
game the other night.
I watched the horn and 80 Ohio state
buckeyes going to be Schwab at shut.
Pank what? The Virginia. Who gives a
fuck? Who Was it? The Virginia Cavaliers.
The volunteers. I don't know what they
are, but they had some very nice helmets.
They did actually had some really nice
helmets and they hung in there with the
buckeyes for about two
and a half quarters.
And all of a sudden Ohio
state was just like, yeah,
we've had about enough of you
guys. Buckeyes look great.
And you know, it's funny.
As much as I was singing hail
to the victors, I actually
sit there and I watched.
I go, God damn it. I love the Buckeyes,
always liked the uniform. And uh,
I've always liked Michigan is I can't help
it. I'm from Boston outside of Boston,
Massachusetts. It's not a college
town, it's a college Savile.
We don't have any good college sports.
Christ,
we had Doug Flutie for like fucking
four years. That's all we had. You know,
we do well in college hockey.
Other than that,
the whole fucking thing fell apart a
couple of times. Umass did okay. You know,
BC did all right. We got to the sweet
16 and the Big Dad, we got nothing.
We got nothing.
All we have is on a professional level.
We just want all the
fucking championships.
That's all that we have to hang our hats
on. So anyway, so I, as I mentioned,
I I like a lot of teams that are our
rivals of each other just because,
uh,
you know,
I've just watched him throughout the
years because they've always been good and
who doesn't want to watch quality
football over there? So anyways,
tonight the NFL season starts,
uh,
du Du, Du, Du, Du.
Ooh,
right?
And I'll tell you,
it's a goddamn shame that the two teams
tonight have collectively one 10 super
bowl championships and they're going
to fucking deal with the all that Jim,
Jim Hearsay.
How did I not fucking come
up with that until now?
Jim and hearsay out and fucking
all of his can't fucking prove it.
But we definitely probably
think that may be new shop too.
Unbelievable for fucking games
and draft picks. It's unreal.
That's what happens when
you're top everybody,
all you guys out there are you fat.
Fuck winging it and fucking jerk offs.
You know what you are.
You guys are all just jelly.
The same shit you put
on your fucking donuts.
That's what you got going on with
the Patriots. Fuck all of you.
I can't hear any of you.
I'm done with it.
Dealt with a custody. I
got into it with this, uh,
with a good friend of mine who was a
Pittsburgh Fan and he explained a way.
Terry Bradshaw's,
we use steroids comment,
but was convinced [inaudible] cell phone.
You know,
why did he destroy his cell phone?
Why didn't Terry Bradshaw's
say you use steroids,
Carrie?
I love sports fans.
Absolutely love them.
They can not see anything wrong
that their own fucking team did.
And I'm going to pause now as a way for
you guys go. Well, what about you bill a,
we cheated in 2007 for one game,
for one game.
We cheated. That was a brand
new rule. We ignored it.
A fucking man genie fucking site.
He called us on it and we were 100%
guilty of cheating one fucking time.
It was a brand new role.
So all you dump concert go well,
what about three to five years early
when you went to know Superbowls? Well,
it wasn't illegal to do that.
You dumb fuck. By the way,
if you ever go to a game,
watch the guys sending in the signals.
And when I say guys, it's plural.
There's always like three or four people
fucking sending signals because they
don't want you to figure it out who?
Because everybody does it now.
Whatever. Suck a dick. Um,
so we're coming out tonight and I'm
hoping that we're going to ask rape the
fucking Steelers and the rest of the
League and win another championship this
year.
Cause I would just love to hear what
Jim Hearsay's going to say or some other
fucking team.
Um,
start some rumor that ESPN then picks
up without even researching and then
apologizes at two in the fucking
morning. Those spineless cunts. Um,
but anyways, who gives a fuck about
all that? It's football season.
The dog days of baseball are behind us.
Baseball's gonna matter.
Football always matters.
Basketball and baseball and hockey
or right around the fucking corner.
This is one of those, one of the
great months of the year, you know,
when the great months a year. And you
know what, there's no bunny rabbit.
There's no fat guy coming
down the fucking thing, right?
Jesus didn't do anything this month.
Jesus didn't do shit.
And September's whole 33 fucking years,
never did a goddamn thing that I have
to pay attention to. Pay attention to.
All you got is like those 19
Jewish holidays of which, you know,
people who aren't even Jewish
get like eight of those days off.
So God bless the Jewish people,
the Jews over the air here in September.
Um, it's a great fucking month.
Hey, you know, the last time I talked
to you guys, I mentioned that I was uh,
using big green egg to finally go and
try and attempt to smoke something.
And I don't think I've ever been so
excited in my life when I got that,
that fire going on at Hickory, wished I
was smoking and all of that stuff. But,
uh, unfortunately my fire
ended up going out about,
um,
about two hours into it.
So my question to other
people who smoke with the egg,
how do you layer your fire?
Cause like I obviously need more charcoal
but I can't have the temperature go
higher than a certain, um, you know,
I want to keep it around like 200,
180 to two 20.
I just put it right at 200 cause
everybody was saying I do it at two 20.
I do a one 80. I do two 10.
I said fuck it. Split the
difference. I have it at 200.
So how do you build that fire where
it's not going to go out in two hours,
but it's not hotter than like 200 degrees
to I like I just don't know how to do
that yet.
And it's,
it's a lot easier with the smoker
because I would think that, you know,
you just keep adding to it.
Although with the smoker,
I heard you start with charcoal and
then the wood starts burning and then he
keep it at that. Well maybe just
add more wood. I don't know.
I'm a complete novice. So
what happened was when I took,
um, you know, when I took the
ribs off after like three hours,
um, and everybody's all three hours.
I do it five hours, I do it 19 hours.
I do it for an hour and a half.
Everybody's got a different,
no fucking idea how to do this shit.
So three hours,
I take it off cause my fire was dying
all the way down and it took them out and
had this,
it looked like they'd been smoked.
So it was already really excited
about that. And then, you know,
I ate one of the small ones and it seemed
to be done and then I cut to the next
one and it looked like a
burger that was medium rare.
So like a fucking asshole.
I was so hungry.
I said to hell with that.
And I bit into it and I chewed
three times and I'm like, Bill,
what the fuck are you doing?
You're eating an under cooked pig,
are you out of your mind?
So I spit it out on the plate and then
I just took all of the ribs and uh,
I put them in like casserole dish.
I put some water in there and a,
I just baked them in the oven to
finish them. And they were delicious.
They definitely had a
smoky flavor, but, uh,
I wanted to finish the
whole thing on the egg.
So if anybody has the big green egg and
you know how to do it, how I maintain a,
a fire, you know, when
they talk about, you know,
if someday I do a brisket or
pork butt or something like that,
how do I maintain that temperature
and that fire for that long?
Do you have a system? Make me a
video for the love of Christ. Um,
but anyways, um, so it
didn't quite work out,
but I knew that that was
going to happen anyways.
I knew I was going to fuck it up the first
time through. Um, but other than that,
everything else was working. And
I'll also, do you guys prefer the,
the hickory chunks or having
those little chips that you soak?
That was another thing because I felt
like the hickory chunks just really just,
just burned right the fuck up. When I
opened it, it was nothing but ashes. So,
uh, I dunno, I got a lot of
questions, but I ain't going to quit.
I'm just going to keep going with it.
So anyways,
another thing in sports that I
forgot to mention is the u s open.
Alright.
And Serena Williams is trying to become,
let's see, actually look this up.
She's trying to become the one,
okay.
Two,
three fourth tennis player all
time to have a season slam,
which is winning all in the same
calendar year. The Australian Open,
the French Open,
Wimbledon and the u s open.
MMM.
I mean there's a shortlist of people that
through their career have won all four.
But um, there's only four people. Three
people. I'm sorry that I've ever done it.
Uh,
Margaret Court did it in 1970.
This is so not the Monday morning podcast.
I actually have information here.
Steffi Graf did it in
1988 and rod fucking away
did it twice,
1962 and 1969 and that is why a lot of
people still consider him arguably the
greatest tennis male tennis
player, I should say, of all time.
MMM.
He won 11 overall end.
He had a,
he had a career and seat career slam.
Obviously he had this season's slam twice.
Nobody's ever done it twice. Um,
so I actually started looking up,
cause I'm like a fucking numbers
nerd when it comes to sports.
So as far as the top ladies,
and granted,
I couldn't find a fucking website
that just listed all of them.
So I just went on Wikipedia and just
started going through all the top, uh,
women that I could remember that I
watched and all that shit. So here,
here's the top women's
tennis champions of all time.
As far as I,
my Wikipedia research,
Margaret Margaret fucking caught
over there. She's one the most.
She won 24. Uh, she won them, uh,
before the open era, which I believe
started in [inaudible] 67 or 68.
I don't even know what the fuck that,
I forget what that means. The Open era.
What does that mean? After the summer of
love, people started whoring it up there.
Uh, sorry. Let me see
what I got here. Close.
Close this window.
Open era tennis. All right,
what the fuck does this mean?
The Open era Wikipedia.
This is where I get all my information.
The period since 1968 where can compete
in a grand slam and grand slams.
Oh, so it wasn't professionals. Well,
that kind of takes a little luster
off of fucking rod laver for me.
We're not in 69, though, but he also
done, I it doesn't because you know what,
he did it in 1969 he did it when
there weren't professionals.
And when there were,
uh,
the open era began in 1968 when the
Grand Slam tournaments agreed to allow
professional players to compete with
amateurs before 1968 only amateurs who are
allowed to compete in the Grand Slam
tournaments and other events organized or
sanctions by the I l t f
including the Davis Cup.
Uh,
the move is made because the English
are tired of the hypocrisy in the sport.
Uh, well that probably means like, you
know, like back in the day when, uh,
the US Olympic team was all amateurs
and so was so was the Russian team,
but they didn't have any
professional fucking sports.
So we were playing against their
Gretzky's with like a r a w.
What's that guy's name?
Six kills six killer was
that Oregon quarterback
or Washington quarterback from way back
in the day, one of the great names ever.
Six killer, right? 76 killer.
I swear to God, that's an actual
name of a quarterback that I learnt.
Sunny fucking six.
Kyla is a former American football
player in sports commentator.
That is the greatest sunny six killer.
Who the fuck would want that guy?
He's a quarterback
born in Oklahoma and is a
member of the Cherokee nation.
Jesus Christ.
If that guy came around today,
it would be marketing gold. Hi. Hey.
Sat a six candidates taking enough failed.
Actually Keith Jackson was, was uh,
was around back there. Sonny
six killer that, I mean,
Quintin Tarantino couldn't come up
with a better fucking name than that.
All right, let's continue
here. So Margaret Court one 24,
um,
mostly during pre open era
in through the last few, uh,
after the opener. Steffi Graf, 22,
a lot of people put her above Margaret
Court because all of hers were during the
Open era when it was all professionals.
Serena, Steffi Graf one 22.
So Margaret Court 24.
Steffi Graf 20 to Serena Williams 21.
Um,
she wins obviously the u s open.
That'll be 22 when she will become
the fourth woman woman of all time.
And the fifth person collectively
ever to have a seasoned slam. Um,
Martina Navratilova,
uh, 18 Chris Everett 18,
Billie Jean King 12. Um,
and then on the men's side,
Roger Federer has one 17
Pete San Fran and has, uh,
uh, uh, uh, career slam.
Uh,
all those women that I just mentioned,
they all have the career slam.
Pete San Francis one 14, but he
never wanted the French. Rafi l made.
Dell has one 14,
but he never went Australia.
But Raphael Nadal has the record since
the open era of winning the most,
a single grand slam event he
won than anybody else. Uh,
he won the French Open.
He wanted nine times in 10 years,
four years in a row,
Mr Year when federal one and 2009.
Then he ran it for another five.
Um,
Rod Laver has 11. Bjorn Borg has 11
never won the u s so the Australian Open,
Andre Agassi has eight, has the
career slam. Avant Lendl has eight.
Never won Wimbledon. Mcenroe has
seven. Never one Roland Garros or uh,
the French or Australian Boris Becker six.
Then I had to look up Stan Smith,
you know, he's got that sneaker like
Jordan that they never retired. I'm like,
I got to see what this guy did.
Stan Smith one too.
Yeah.
He never won the Australian or the
U Open this mother Fucker, man.
How the hell did you get a sneaker?
Let's see when he won it.
Now that I know what the open
Arrow means. Stan Smith. Yeah.
He wanted the open air and he went
72 we won Wimbledon and the US Open.
He wanted 71 I know, I sound
like the fucking rain man, but I,
I get into this type of shit.
MMM.
So anyways, let's go, let's
get back to the podcast here.
So I'm looking forward to it.
You know,
if you don't watch tennis but you want
to pop in when you can see something that
net that rarely ever happens. You got
to watch Serena Williams this weekend.
You don't have to,
but she can.
MMM.
All right, let's plow ahead here. Uh Oh.
Let's talk about fucking
working out old Billy fat tits.
Huh?
Oh Billy fucking baby
bump. I'm back on it, man.
I went on a hike the other day and
I worked out did all of that shit.
I woke up in the morning,
but I do buy dope and I weighed
myself before working out,
which I've now learned is your
most accurate weight of the day.
And I was one 65.8 so that means I am in
striking distance of getting down to my
bucks. 62 I'm going to, I might have to
fucking skip a rope. Yeah, skip a rope,
skip rope for a couple of rounds to get
down to it. But uh, I think I can do it.
And then I start back out on the road.
I'm going back east,
I'm going to a wedding and a then
I do my run through Texas. So, uh,
this is going to be the
tough thing. And also my, uh,
my boos fast is going to end at
some point over the next week.
I am up to a, what's today? Thursday?
Sunday was 63, 64, 65, 66, 67 days.
And I wanted to go like 70, 72 days.
So I've got like five more days.
MMM.
But I got to tell you tonight,
I might
actually fuck it up tonight all
depending on what happens. Actually.
Got a great gig tonight, um, through
a friend of a friend of a friend.
Somehow I am.
Okay.
I am going to,
I'll tell you later who I'm open at for.
I'll tell you the next time, cause I
don't know if it's a secret fucking Gig,
but um,
I'm opening for uh,
a bunch of um,
oh,
a bunch of young lads that like
to go to the library and uh,
they might want to go to the library
tonight and who am I to say no,
at least got to read one book
with them, right? Anyways,
so all I gotta do is, uh, just eat right.
Do a little bit of cardio.
I think I can get down there and um,
but what I'm really finding is all I'm
going to do is lose a little more muscle
and I'm still going to have
this fucking God damn baby bump.
I can't get rid of the fucking thing.
However,
however I actually have started the
transformation of my garage not being a
place to dump shit off
at. I am now going, it's,
it's making is trans transformation.
All right.
I had three cabinets sitting on the floor,
pieces of absolute fucking shit cabinets,
but they still work. So I had somebody
come over, he fucking, you know,
did the whole stud finder thing.
I wasn't going to do it because I'm
putting my tools in there and a bunch of
shit from my big green egg.
It's going to be heavy.
And I don't need to pull out a bunch of
dry wall cause I fucking miss the stud.
I don't give a fuck. I'm a
comedian. I understand it.
I don't want somebody who's
in construction to tell me
jokes and I don't want to
be fucking hanging cabinets. All right,
question my manhood. I don't give a fuck.
So this dude, he put up the, um,
he put up the cabinets,
had a ladder, hung up,
and I had bolt bicycles hung up and a,
I came downstairs with an apron and
you know, gave him some muffins.
They good little housewife and a,
so that's the beginning of it.
And then I'm going to,
on craigslist,
I'm going to get rid of my pull
up and dip station, then I,
that I bought and I'm going to, uh, get
a pull up bar that mounts to the wall.
And then I'm going to go to that,
those atomic grips website and a,
I'm getting all those, those fucking,
uh, those little cannon ball things,
whatever you call them,
the fucking missiles and all those things,
all those different grip things.
And I'm going to get, and um,
I'm going to have my own little,
uh,
American Ninja fuck an obstacle course
hanging from the ceiling of my, uh,
my garage.
And that's going to be my workout.
And I figure if I do that throughout
the years, skip a little rope,
take my dog for a hike.
And as long as I don't eat like a cunt,
I think I should be all right.
You know,
cause I fucking hate going to the gym
even though I like going to the gym.
You know,
what was the last time you went to the
gym and you wanted to go and use the
bench press? And there wasn't fucking
12 people waiting for it, right?
Or even worse, even worse,
the fucking chick who's there,
who's not even bench pressing and
is using it to sit on the end of it.
It fucking, uh, uh, Jesus.
Hang on a second. Let me,
let me call you right back. I'm finishing
up my up, my podcast. All right,
no problem. All right. Um,
the chick that's sitting on the end of
the bench to do some fucking ab work or
do some like, you know, those,
those tricep exercises and you
got what you want to be like, hey,
why didn't you go over to
the the mat area and do that?
But you can't do that because if you ever,
you could say that to a guy,
but if you say it's a woman
than your acts sexist work,
you wait your turn, you
fucking pig. Um, so you,
you want to avoid that, right? So, um,
and what I like about the way I'm
going to do my garage is everything's,
everything that I'm working out with is
hanging up on the wall or hanging from
the ceiling. Do you know a long time
ago I bought the rings, you know,
this gymnastic rings when I
had a one bedroom apartment,
which is fucking hilarious.
I Dunno where I thought it
was going to hang on for me.
That was going to hanging from my chin up
bar and uh, and it just, nothing worked.
It was just too, it was too,
I was too low to the ground.
And,
uh,
also I put up the chin up bar so I never
truly trusted that that thing wasn't
going to give way. And I had, I had
to have my legs bent when I used them,
so I was like,
I'm either going to fucking land on my
knee caps or I'm going to land on my
tailbone and either way it's going to
suck. So, uh, I'm going to get though,
I'm just going to have these hook things
up there so I could just, you know,
put shit up and take stuff down and uh,
she could tell him I'm fucking
beyond excited about it and
I can take my useless termite
infested fucking hunk of shit.
Cock sucking mother fucking garage.
Yeah.
That's shaped like an ice cream cone that
was made out of wax and was stuffed in
an oven for 20 minutes and
then pulled out not 20 minutes,
whatever it first starts
to melt. Um, even the, uh,
the guy,
the construction dude who was helping
me put that up with saying that the,
the garage itself was an
optical illusion as far as like,
I was telling him like he saw on the wall,
thank God it's just shitty drywall.
Like I've scraped,
you know,
my bumper's hit the side of it a couple
of times cause it's, it's coming in,
I'm looking onto the left because
that's like cinder blocks and concrete.
So I mean this thing was built for a
model t Ford. I'm getting a 68, uh,
f 100 in there, so it gets a little tight,
you know, hey, it gets a little rough,
you know, so I'm, I'm paying attention
to the fucking concrete. And uh,
on the other side it comes in at like a
15 degree angle and then all of a sudden
it just increases to like 18 or 19
degrees and the wall is all white.
See just, you can't even fucking see
it. And, uh, you know, it's a truck.
Nothing happens to the truck. It just puts
a hack mark in the fucking wall. And a,
I'm actually tempted to talk to
my neighbor and be like, dude,
how much would it cost for
me to buy one foot your way?
The length of my garage?
Can I buy that property off of you and
build a garage that's fucking square?
Can you do that for me? I wonder
what he would say. He probably said,
well, you know what? Go Fuck Yourself.
And I'd be like, you know what?
That's probably exactly what I would say.
Why do I give a fuck about your garage
and your problem? I don't give a shit. Um,
so anyways, uh, last night I worked
out some material. Jesus Christ was,
I fucking
just rusty last night was a lot
of work. It's all I can say. Oh,
by the way. So the big college game
that I'm going to this year is, uh,
well I'm going to one,
I'm going to Texas and Osu and because
I'm getting ready for that Madison Square
Garden show.
Um,
I'm doing another big tour in
October and that one starts off,
we're going to go to a Notre Dame USC,
and that is the entire Rosebowl Kuru
Kuru crew is going to that game.
Bart, nick lie ahead and myself and,
um, that's how we start to tore off.
We just got some nosebleed seats
up at the top of the stadium.
So if you're going to the
game, look for the, uh,
me and five other people
that come stumbling in, um,
to watch that game.
I'm actually not going to get too ripped
for that famous last words, but, uh,
I think,
you know,
I want to watch that game because I think
Notre Dame and is going to be really
good this year. I don't know
about USC. I know that they won,
but I don't know that they've
played yet. Um, but it's, you know,
like I said, I hope Michigan
gets good. It's good to see
Notre Dame good again. Uh,
you know, it's good for college football
even though, you know, it's like I said,
it was a red sox fan. It's good when the
fucking red sox and Yankees are good. Um,
speaking of which, we suck that
Dick this year. All right, let's,
let's read some of the advertising here
and so I can wrap this up. All right.
The Zip recruiter,
a business owners,
did you know that summer is a grand
time to hire the best people with,
uh,
with your competitors on vacation?
There's less competition
for quality candidates,
but posting your job in one
place isn't enough to find them.
And when you're short staffed,
there's no time to deal with the
dozens of different job sites on
no
thanks to zip recruiter.com you can
post to a hundred plus job sites with a
single click of your mouse
there of you still use one.
Just post once within 24 hours. Watch
your candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface plus be instantly
matched to candidates from over 4
million resumes.
Ziprecruiter has been used by over 400,000
businesses and you can try it right
now for free.
Try Zip recruiter and get
your preferred candidate, um,
this summer before they
go to somebody else today.
You can try ZipRecruiter for real.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/burr.
That's ziprecruiter.com/burr.
Hey,
zip recruiter.com/bar.
Alright, next. Lastly,
but not leastly Uber.
Okay.
How great is Uber? If the booze, that's
one thing that they won't bring up.
I mean the amount of lives that they must
save every year because you could just
get yourself a designated driver
because it designated driver thing.
Never really worked did it?
It's really hard to be hanging around a
bunch of people drinking and then you're
not going to drink, you know,
cause they're going to get
hammered and be like, who?
I, hey you guys. Right?
The next thing you know,
next thing you know. Yeah.
Hammered sitting in the
drive through at Mcdonald's.
Woo. Uh, Uber. Hey, you
like making great money,
right? Sure. We all do.
Here's a really cool opportunity I have
to share with you driving with Uber or
driving with Uber.
Yeah.
Uber's that popular smart phone APP
that connects writers with drivers.
Uh, people take Uber a bunch.
People love them by the way.
And in chatting with the
different drivers. Some of
them have really interesting,
really interesting stories
as why they drive with Uber.
Here's some right here. They love being
their own boss. They earned great money.
It's easy to say that all you need is
a car and a license and a little bit of
motivation. Driving with Uber is great
for anyone who needs flexibility.
Parents, this is a really easy way to work
around your family schedule. Students.
You can make some extra money between
classes, no more stripping the,
that was the prime time to catch a,
to cash in driving with Uber.
You'll thank me for telling
you how to get paid every week.
I could be getting into your
car when you drive with Uber.
I'll tell you right now, I won't be
sober. Uh, you got a car and a license.
Put a boat to work for you and
start earning serious money,
serious life changing money today.
Sign up with Uber to drive.
Sign up to drive with Uber.
Visit drive with uber.com
that's drive with U B E r.com.
Drive with uber.com. All right, let's uh,
okay,
let's try and wrap this up.
What the fuck was I just going to tell
you guys about something dumb that I did?
Okay.
Something dumb that I didn't know
what happened right before this, uh,
my doorbell rang and the guy came over
with the samples of the different stayed
because my front gate is about ready to
fall down as are the driveway gates. Uh,
cause they're, you know, absolute piece of
shit, cock suck and motherfucking gates.
You know,
not to be confused with my cock sucking
mother fucking piece of shit garage or
the cock sucking mother
fucking conti plumbing in, in,
in cloth wiring in the walls.
But slowly but surely, you know,
we're getting this thing together
fucking unreal.
Ah, whenever I think about this house,
how long it's been around in all that,
I just think of like, remember
that game, the wonderful though.
Wander ball goes round and round.
Bapapapapa you are bound to Turo too
when you are last and you are out o u t
out.
That's what it feels like.
Everybody just kept passing the
buck and by the time I got it,
the fucking shit hit the fan.
But um,
I take some perverse pleasure in being
the one that fixes up this fucking house.
You don't just to know whoever I sell
this to isn't going to, you know,
isn't going to inherit a
bunch of fucking problems.
Okay.
Do you know they went up on the
roof and they told me, once again,
we're having an El Nino when these
guys fucking put the drains too high.
It's just a never ending.
This would be the third time I
have to get my fucking roof fixed.
And I know what you guys
are thinking. Well Bill, why
don't you just sue somebody?
I'll tell you why.
Cause I don't want to go to court.
I don't want to fucking sit there and
have those guys string it out for three
years. This was is, it continues to
rain down into my fucking living room,
whatever. I picked a couple
of dopes. I'm all for two.
I think I finally found somebody fucking
reputable and they'll do the thing
right. I don't even want to
talk about it. So anyways, um,
my, uh, prediction tonight is it's
got to be a tough game as always.
Uh, I have no idea what the Patriots
are going to be like. As always,
whenever you win a championship, a
bunch of people jump ship. And, um,
I definitely think not having
Reavis is really going to affect us.
Um, Rothfuss burgers to time winning
champions, Superbowl champion.
And I think a Steelers always have a
good defense. Who the fuck knows? Man?
It's the first God damn week.
But I got to tell you, I'm,
I'm really excited that I'm celebrating
how long Spanish fantasy football been
around. I love that. I
still don't play that shit.
I got a, I got asked to join another
league, you know what I mean?
Uh, this year and I just wrote, I
don't play pan is fantasy football.
You guys are all a bunch of
pussies and I didn't write pussies,
if you know what I mean. And then the
dude just wrote back, he wrote, Lol,
I really wish I could argue
that. Um, Oh, speaking of which,
you know what Rappaport he's fucking
told me about this thing that he did. Um,
okay.
I got to find it meant,
uh,
did anybody listened to Michael Rappaport
when he was on the Howard Stern show?
Yeah,
when he played fantasy football against
the fantasy football guy and he won,
he had his son pick out the fucking teams
and evidently he was shit talking and
this guy wasn't good at shit-talking any,
absolutely buried him on the
fucking Howard stern show.
I'm trying to find the clip.
If anybody has the clip,
please send it to me and
then I will retweet it. Um,
I'll retweet it. Uh, you know,
on the podcasts Twitter account and
by saying I've been trying to do it,
my fucking died. I got a new hard
drive put into an it shit the bed.
So, uh, I just said fuck it. And I went
out and I bought like an $800 laptop,
laptop. Fucking, I'm done
buying expensive ones,
not like 800 bucks. That's, that's, you
know, that's cheap for a fucking laptop.
So, uh, I'm not, and this is a great
thing about this one, this laptop,
I'm not putting any information on it.
I'm not putting any of my fucking music
on it. I'm not putting anything on it.
So when it inevitably shits the bed,
you know, did you save it to the iCloud?
Fuck the ICLOUD.
Fuck the ICLOUD and fuck
Disneyland and Fuck Disney world.
I read up on that Shit, dude. That
is so God damn creepy how they're,
they're going to going to microchip you
when you go in and out of that park the
entire fucking time.
And the only way to fight it is to
just not go because you can't have an
intelligent conversation with most
people because most people are morons.
Most people be like,
why do I give a fuck if they know
where I bought a fucking slurpee?
I don't give a shit as long as
it's up on space mountain, right.
They don't give a shit.
And it's so perfect because eventually
when the government microchips, everybody,
one of the arguments is
going to be like, well, you,
they microchip you when
you go to Disneyland.
Do you think that Mickey mouse is evil?
Dude,
I was reading this thing
where they literally,
you're going to go in there and the people
dressed up as the characters are just
going to come up to you and be like,
hey bill, how's it going? I'm sorry.
I almost said it's Pluto. That's when
you know you're doing a bad impression.
We have to say who the fuck it is. Hello?
Low. This is Arnold Schwarzenegger. Um,
like those characters are going to come
walking up and saying hello to you.
All right.
So if you're walking in there with that
wristband that is tracking you from a
fucking satellite in outer space and
Pluto comes up to you and knows your name
before you introduce yourself, and in the
meantime in the background is singing.
It's a small world.
After all, if the, the,
that Trifecta of Shit doesn't
creep you out, then uh,
I think you're a robot. Either that or
you deserve whatever happens to you,
what you're in there.
You know what I mean?
Those fucking creeps over a Disney.
What do they not going to be crepes.
Arthur Ashe award.
The Caitlyn Jenner.
So you get the fucking exclusive
interview with Diane Sawyer.
Okay.
Ah, shameless. Absolutely
fucking shameless. All alleged.
But I feel after that whole deflate
gate thing, it doesn't matter.
All you gotta do is you just say
shit and then it becomes true.
All right everybody, that's the
Thursday afternoon podcast. Uh,
hope you guys have a great weekend.
[inaudible] and joy,
some throwback Monday morning podcast
stuff. And I'm hoping for a great game.
Obviously hoping the
Patriots win tonight and um,
but I got no beef with the
fucking Steelers or anything
that they've ever done,
including what Terry said. I don't
give a shit. Congratulations.
You've won six Superbowls
as far as I'm all right.
Go fuck yourself and a Seattle.
I hope you made you stadium even louder.
God knows your lame ass fans
need all the help they can get.
Come on, man. I had to start
shit with somebody. Um,
I actually think Seattle is probably
going to be good this year. Oh. Oh.
Pete Carroll. Oh, Pete
Carroll. There's another,
there's an upstanding individual
bill Bella checks a piece of shit.
But I'll tell you that Pete Carroll.
Oh pistol Pete.
You know what the genius of Pistol
Pete sees his filthy as anybody,
but he dresses like
Flanders on the Simpsons.
That's what Bella check
should be doing. Oh, hoodies.
Just evil people don't trust you,
but you put on a pair of dockers,
you know what I mean?
Keep you stomach down
and go woo.
After every fucked up play. God dammit.
People will love you. All right,
go fuck yourselves. Uh, I have a
great weekend and enjoy the throwback
Monday morning podcast.
Wait
the
car
with us.
Oh two eight. Bill, maybe you
can help me out with this thing.
I haven't read any of these things
people. So, uh, bear with me here. Uh,
this sounds ridiculous,
but hear me out.
I met this girl a couple of weeks ago
and I've been talking to her and hanging
out with her nonstop.
We is pretty what? I
guess it's, she is pretty,
she's pretty funny,
intelligent and one of the most upfront
and upfront and honest people I've ever
met in my life. In fact,
maybe a little too honest,
cause she tells me every day how
great, cute, honest and honest I am.
And it's a little much sometimes.
Anyways,
we've been hitting it off like crazy and
on Saturday she spent the night and we
hung out all day Sunday about nine
around 9:00 PM we got on the topic of old
jobs. Uh, fuck is she a dancer?
And she told me that a few years
ago she worked in a pet store. Okay.
I guess wrong.
There was a hamster there that would
bite her everyday drawing blood and what?
Attack coworkers and customers generally
the hamster was a crazy douche.
One day her,
her and a coworker decided they had to
do something about this thing to put the
hamster in a bag and
smashed it against the wall.
Whoa.
What?
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking left turn that was.
They put it in a bag
and smashed it against the wall.
Needless to say,
I was shocked.
The first thing I said was,
Holy Shit Lady.
That's kind of crazy.
That makes
wait.
That's the kind of crazy that makes
a wife cut her husband's Dick off.
I'm sorry dude.
That was a hilarious line and I blew it.
The first thing I said was,
Holy Shit Lady.
That's the kind of crazy that makes
it wife cut her husband's Dick off.
She said she still feels horrible about
it and that she killed it that way
because she couldn't think of any
other way to make it quick. But Jeez,
I mean, I never been in that situation,
but that seems kind of crazy. Lol.
This seems like something straight
out of a Seinfeld episode,
but I just keep thinking about it.
Every time me and this chick's are,
are getting together,
should I just accept this is a crazy
story or is this a sign that she has
serious issues?
Remember,
this happened years ago and she
seems absolutely sane. Otherwise,
please help potential murder
victim question mark through.
Some of you guys are really fucking funny,
man. The way you guys write this shit.
I, I you, but you got to admit I
haven't proved with my reading.
I feel so bad that I butchered
that God damn line. Um,
okay.
Okay. Jesus Christ. What
do you do with this one?
This is fucked up on so
many different levels. Okay,
let's start with the first thing.
The cruelty to animals.
Okay.
Not only cruelty to animals
like I could what she did,
I could do that to an aunt.
I won't even do it to a spider.
I could do it to a fucking mosquito.
That's what she basically treated
a hamster like a fucking mosquito.
Now granted a hamster. Okay, let's
try to be a little empathetic here.
Empathetic.
Let me try to put myself in her situation.
If I was younger,
20 years younger and a hamster bit me
every day at work and I met working at a
fucking pet store, uh, what?
I smashed it against the wall and
a bag. No, I wouldn't. However,
I would do something to it.
I would do something. Do you know
what I would do? I would take a ruler.
I would wait.
I would wait till it was a fallen asleep
and I would just write on it's fucking
hamster ass and it woke up.
Fuck it did.
I would just take the ruler and I
would pin it against the fucking cage.
It just watch you get all
upset. I just, I would bully it.
That's what basically what I would do.
Hey, you liked that. You liked that?
Your little fucking Hamster, Huh? I
wouldn't hurt it. I just keep it pinned.
I was frustrated. I would frustrate
the living shit out of it.
That's what I would do.
I would do something like that.
I that I think I would do that,
but I would not smash it against the
fucking wall. They put it in a bat.
Now did,
was it repeated strikes?
Jesus Christ, you know some of this
shit kids used to do in my neighborhood.
Do you know I had a friend of mine,
he's take his house cat and he put in
an empty Pellis pillowcase and he would
fucking spin it over his head like
someone like it was at a Steelers game,
you know,
that's what the fuck you would do.
And then sometimes he'd
put it in the dryer.
They used to tell me these stories and
I used to laugh my fucking ass off for
some reason.
I found it funny back then.
Now I find it absolutely horrific and uh,
I would never do it,
but if I had to do it
either or a dog or a cat,
I would definitely do it to a cat.
But it have to be a real douche of a cat.
All right,
so we're getting off the subject here.
So it's cruelty to animals
and she works at a pet store.
So that's bizarre because he
figured if you work at a pet store,
that means you either you
love animals or use you.
Like I had a low level deal pot. You, you,
you're dealing weed on a low level.
You know what I mean? You're that guy.
You like the burnout, Matthew mcconaughey.
At least that's how they used to be.
But then there's the other option
that serial killers, you know,
they start off with small animals.
You know,
they watch a ton of porn and they start
torturing small animals and then they
gradually work their way up, uh, you know,
to a fucking human being.
So yeah, you could possibly,
you could possibly be dealing with
that right now. Then also, you know,
you're looking at it like this is,
that's the mother. Your children
put a hamster in a fucking,
I could see if it was
fucking 1911 rather than 2011
people back then. They kill
an animal. They didn't give
a fuck. They just walk out.
What do you guys want for
dinner? Yeah, yeah. It's,
has some goose in the
fucking mom would walk out.
They grabbed the goose by the neck and
then they'd fucking act like they were
trying to start up a model t
and they'd go, ah, fucking body.
Then they would just break
its neck nice and quick. Um,
and then they'd pluck it, Nick Cook
it and that was it. And that was,
that was dinner 1911. Do you like that
little piece? A piece of history? Uh,
attitude. I don't know what
to tell you. This is like, um,
that's really fucking
insane and at the very least
if you get into a fight with her eye,
she's at the very least,
I think she's going to throw something
at you. She might be one of those.
I have no idea. Dude.
How hard is this girl?
I think some of these people I need like
a picture to see if it's like worth it.
You guys seem to be connecting
on like a personality level,
but I really got to tell you,
you know,
that's just like something
Roger Clemens would do.
I could picture him doing that.
You know,
he is that pose posey from the
fucking dirty dozen sort of vibe.
Yes.
All right, here we go. All right, Bill.
One of my best friends has been going to
church for years and previously it has
never bothered me at all.
Well, Gigi, I grew up,
I grew up Catholic and like so many
Catholics I got raped. No kidding.
I no longer, I no longer attend church,
but it doesn't bother me in the least.
If someone else wants to go,
this guy is the exact mindset than I am
except by make fun of people who go to
church a little bit, little
bit. A few months ago,
my friends started asking me if I would
like to go to church with him gay.
Uh, I plight. I politely declared that's,
that's a gay thing to do and I don't mean,
I don't mean nick.
How is it gay to ask someone to go to
church with you because you're both going
to be wearing sweaters.
You're going to be singing songs.
You are
oh, lay Lou. Yah.
You'll just sit there and sing with it.
You have fucking friend wearing a sweater
and then, then the priest up there,
God knows what he did.
It's going to be like he had a beard
and some long hair. Really? He cared.
A leper.
Not of you guys can do that.
So you better give us some money.
Yeah. Who are not making fun of mass right
now. It's great to you. It's nothing.
Yes. Granted, there are
some things that are not,
none of that horse shit
that overly boodley
hopefully bullied to him. Well, it's like
a call and response. I'll tell you what,
I'll tell you what's fucking sacred.
Meaning the rest of question.
Now you're getting the answer.
Touch. I'll tell you what's sacred.
What's sacred is how you go out in the
playoffs. The Celtics went out with heart.
We still lost the fucking, we still
got our ass. We still got arrested.
We still got our asses kicked. All right?
But there was no quit in that team.
All right? Okay. That's
fucking sacred. What?
Sac religious is what the fucking Lakers
Dick. And I'm like disrespect in the,
I'm saying what? The couple of those
and it wasn't all of them. What? Uh,
it was really what buying him did.
I didn't think but Odom did was bad.
Can you just finish reading Jesus Christ?
Really?
All of a sudden you're dictating it.
You asked me why.
So he wants to go to church
with me. With him. I repeat gay.
I politely decline. Dude,
I'm not doing that shit.
You're all commentary.
That's not a part of the letter because
you're presenting it and then a biased
fashion. This, read it and then give
your opinion. You see this shit.
This is a classic fucking broad.
It's like I've been doing this shit for
four years and you're telling me how to
run it yet you have no idea how many
more on guys are going to send him hate
mail because of that, because not because
you're a jerk, because some other, well,
they're morons.
Fucking elitist attitude.
Um,
since then my friend has told me he feels
it's his mission to spread the word of
God.
Stop saying it like that
and continues to ask me to go. They
got, he drank the fucking cool light.
Now he's a Zombie and as time pass is,
he's getting more aggressive
with his sales pitch.
That means he's probably reaching
out and touching his hand. Uh,
what started off with him just slipping
it into casual conversation is loud now
led me to receiving text
messages that say the following,
this means more to you.
This means more to me than you know.
God has poured out love to me and he is
reaching out to you also ignore a few
months, but there is a lot
at stake here. Wow. Yeah,
no, he has a little ones.
He's buying into that.
Jesus is coming back and this
time he's not fucking around.
It's personnel. Yeah. Okay, so
he's buying into the rapture.
This hippie is going to come back on
a stegosaurus and just start killing
people, killing people. What they
say, what they say is fucking wrong.
He's going to come back wrath.
One of the deadly sins,
Judge's judgment is mine set at the Lord.
He's the son.
He's the Donald Trump. He's got the fuck
he's got to call him over at this point,
coming out of heaven. He didn't make that
money. He didn't make the fucking world.
He's just this loud jackass a
fucking fuck. You know, whatever.
Cast me into the fucking pits.
I don't give a shit. You know,
you think I want to hang out with
you in heaven forever. Just go it.
Isn't this awesome?
It is awesome.
Can you please finish the
letter? All right. What started
off? Okay, so here we go.
Uh, to be to this. I replied,
honestly, it's it, if it's my choice,
I don't want to go.
Please stop asking me about it.
I don't know how many more ways
I can request that they go. Okay.
He responded with, I'll
hold off, but know this,
God loves you and will not quit if I do.
Okay, well then there's no
reason to hit me two times.
Let's just let God do it. All right.
Anyways, here. Cause my question, Bill,
why does this fucking Piss me off so much?
Why did these, why did these cults do,
uh,
what do these cults do to these people?
He's involved with the Church that people
do joke around with and call a cult.
What would you do if you
were me at this point?
I don't even want to talk to this guy
cause he's conversations are infuriating
me. Um, yeah, I would, I would
cut this guy out of your life.
It's annoying. This is what it
is. Why you feel that way? No,
but this is his friend Fred.
It's his friend and he and he wa he
wants to get them out of the cult.
So the thing is is if you go to him
and you try to get them out of it,
you just going to drive
them further into it.
So what you do is just say he just
stopped being friends with them, you know,
and hope that that'll help because they're
not going to go out of that then he's
not going to leave it if you ask them to
leave it. Yeah. You never, you never know.
But yeah, he needs to just kind of
mouth cause yeah, there's no, you can't,
unless he wants to spend the rest
of his time with his guide debating
Catholicism or whatever, which I'm sure
he doesn't want to do. And then yeah,
he should just kinda mom personally,
I would still hang out with them.
And you would just so you could
get into debates with him? No,
and I would just do unbelievably
say titanic been annoying shit.
That good idea. I would, I
would list, he should do that.
I would always have like shout
at the devil playing, you know,
or maybe just that beginning cheesy thing.
She didn't invite women to a restaurant
and it turns out to be like a strip club
and see what he does.
Yeah,
but you're going to see the titties on
the outside gentleman's club. That's true.
No, I wouldn't do that shit. I would just,
I would hang out with
him and hang out with,
I would keep saying that I want to get
involved in the church and I would keep
going to events and as they were going,
you know,
I just feel so filled up with God's love.
I would then be a,
you want to talk about filled
up? I fucking jerked off
into this chick's mouth.
Like I'm telling you, William Byrd,
she had a big bass miles and I dunno,
maybe it was a couple of days since
the last time I fucking, you know,
let them loose. But I right up to the
brim. She was a champion. She swallowed,
I'm sorry, what were you saying?
This is why you're going there now.
Oh,
why don't you pray for me?
Yes.
Yeah.
Um, there was a lot of shit
this, that fucking annoyed
me.
Um,
on the gas mileage thing I brought up
last week how I was watching the good bye
girl and she was standing at
the corner of the characters,
was standing in front of
a fucking Subaru and uh,
it got 39 miles per gallon and here it
is 36 years later and my car only gets
fucking enough.
A hybrid only gets 41 miles per gallon.
So this brilliant guy writes in and he
goes and he starts talking about leaded
gas and all this fucking Ho
how cars today are heavier.
This fucking Moron thought cars today
were heavier than cars back in the day.
You know,
like the 1959 Cadillac,
I'm sure that that car was lighter
than your average Toyota Camry.
Okay.
So anyways, this, somebody sent me, let
me, let me actually read this guy's,
this guy's response here. One
of the many that I got. Um,
on the gas mileage thing, it always blows
my mind what people fucking respond to.
So this guy ends up writing me a,
he goes, there are two reasons.
Wait a minute,
it's loading.
Okay,
loading.
I don't know.
He gave me all these fucking reasons
and I basically responded with so basic,
you're telling me, he basically said
that it had nothing to do with money.
It had to do with the way
to the cars and somehow the,
the mixture of the gasoline
that we use nowadays.
That's why they just can't figure out a
fucking way to get more than like better
than what's the highest you've seen?
Like 40 45 this guy tried to say,
well actually there,
there are things that get a hundred
miles to gallon their scooters. Uh,
what a more rod he goes.
It's true reason why old cars have
such highly high published gas mileage.
For one, the EPA test simply
used to provide higher numbers.
Sir, they've been doing
that right up until the last
couple of years ago. In fact,
the year before I bought my Prius,
they were legally able to claim that it
got like 55th I actually almost 60 miles
per gallon before they cracked down on
the hybrid and made him say actually 40
ones.
I'm aware of the EPA test.
I'm aware that they do it
when there's no headwind.
I'm aware that most of the test is when
they're fucking going 25 miles an hour
and they only drive the car 55 miles
an hour for about fucking 30 seconds.
I realize that the numbers are skewed.
Okay.
He said it's been revised several times
over the decade. Yeah, so my Prius,
you're Prius would get like 70 miles
per gallon on the old test. No,
it wasn't sir. No, it wouldn't. It would
get more like 60 that's what it did look.
So let's just say that it would
get 70 who gives a shit? He goes,
wait, where am I? The second
reason is safety features.
Check out the weight of your cars
have gotten heavier. No, they have it.
My Prius is not heavier
than a fucking Subaru.
Yeah.
In the 1970s it isn't.
Okay,
dude, I'm old enough to remember when cars
actually had metal on their dashboard.
They're all plastics hunks of shit now.
Yeah.
He goes, cars, if even 15 years ago,
feature death traps when compared
to the modern cars. No, they didn't.
They've had the crumple free zones.
Those, those little crumpled freak,
they've had those crumple zones for years,
sir.
In 19 fucking 88 I was coming home from
a Christmas party drunk off my ass,
sitting in the fucking passenger
seat of a Pontiac Grand Prix.
We pulled up to a red light.
There was a fucking jeep CJ seven
the old school ones sitting there.
All right. We saw it. I saw
it. The driver's saw it,
but the alcohol didn't quite
see it and we just sorta went.
We were slowing down,
but we didn't come to us.
Complete slow stop and just
completely rear ended. This guy.
All right. There wasn't a
scratch on the fucking jeep.
This goddamn carp folded up
like a fucking accordion.
The engine dropped down
underneath us and I, I got,
I didn't even get a booboo.
I just Sorta, you know,
I didn't have a seatbelt on or nothing.
The car was designed to take
80% of the fucking impact.
All right. You're sitting in your cubicle.
Just toss in these fucking numbers out.
All right,
so basically my response is,
I'm saying it has nothing to do
with money in the oil companies.
So basically what you're telling me
is that nowadays I can have a video
conference with somebody in Brazil while
my entire music collection is in my
pocket on a phone that is also
a camera and a video recorder.
I can upload the content onto the
Internet and potentially have it viewed by
every person in the fucking world.
But we can't make a car that does
any better than 40 miles per gallon.
So fortunately, you know, everything
else has fucking progressed
except for gas mileage.
Dude, I'm telling you,
they have the technology to
get like 500 miles per gallon.
They're just not going
to fucking put it out,
okay.
Because that's how powerful the
God damn oil companies are there.
Right up there with the banks.
You got the banks and then
you've got the oil company.
The banks control the money supply,
and then the oil companies,
they control energy.
Okay.
Okay. You control energy. You can control
the fucking population. Do you know that?
They're actually out here.
This people,
this selling kits out here to have your
own fucking windmill so you can get
yourself off the grid. So then they
immediately pass the fucking law,
General Electric,
that General Electric had to come around
and make sure that everything was safe.
They had to get their
fucking noses back in there.
So cause they can't have people
disappearing off the fucking grid.
Okay?
You can't have people getting free
energy other than the cost of the fucking
windmill.
You can't have them sitting there.
And every time the God damn wind blows,
it recharges a generator and now I don't
have to work as much if I don't have to
work as much.
I don't have to go into debt.
You're getting yourself off of the fucking
treadmill and they can't have that.
All right.
God dammit.
I wish I was more intelligent so I could
explain this better. But you know what,
this is a great documentary.
I'm actually going to email this guy back.
It's called the gas
whole full documentary.
And there's the they and
they have everything from,
okay.
They have everything from the,
the,
the urban myth of the
watered powered carburetor,
which this guy who are brought
to me completely dismissed.
He completely dismissed any sort
of a that, that, that, that,
that exists because he sits in a cubicle
and I sit in the fucking bedroom,
all right? And he tries to
just say, that's just another
media hoax. All, you know,
they said, do we beat Eisenhower?
A fucking like dumb shit like that.
Okay.
This guy,
so this documentary,
I have everything from like the
urban myths that the, that these, uh,
water powered cars existed,
um,
all the way up to actual, uh, retired, um,
scientists who worked for Shell,
who you just have to watch this
documentary. They were showing,
there was a book out that claimed that
they could get a 149 miles per gallon in
the 1950s on like a Packard or de Soto.
And by the 70s this scientist who worked
for Shell said they had gotten it up to
a thousand miles per gallon.
All right.
I don't know why people think
that it's,
it's
absolutely impossible to improve the
gas mileage. Some people feel that.
I don't know why people feel like we can't
come up with anything better than the
gas combustion engine.
It's complete fucking book.
It's the same level of bullshit as that.
There's an actual difference
between a Democrat and a Republican.
Watch this documentary,
the gas hole.
We're going to have the link up
on the Monday morning podcast.
Just watch this shit and I don't know
what to tell you. Some of it looks like,
okay, they have this
old guy going, you know,
and this guy showed up and he heard it
was a contraption made auto, you know,
it was powered on water and then he
claimed that Shell bought the patent,
gave him $1 million and then he
could never fucking, you know,
make another one now.
That's the kind of Shit,
some old guy saying that he saw it on
a salt flat in the 1950s I'm not going
with that. All right? I'm not
that much of a fucking whack job,
but when a guy who worked used to work
for Shell is coming out saying that type
of stuff, it's just, it gets to the
point like, are all of these people nuts?
You know what I mean?
There's no fucking way. I don't give
a shit whether there's led and gas,
whether there's not led and how much
the car fucking ways or any of that
bullshit.
There's no fucking way.
Okay.
That in, in, in almost 40 years,
you can't do better than
two more miles per gallon.
I absolutely fucking refuse to believe it.
I fucking refuse to believe it.
I think it's complete fucking horseshit.
It's just another way to, to
keep control of the herd. Now,
if you want to argue that you need to
keep control to her or this is going to be
absolute chaos,
so we have to keep cars down like that.
I will listen to that argument.
But if you're going to come at me
and tell me that in 2000 fucking 11
okay,
okay. When I'm reading shit
that in the medical field,
they can now grow a fucking a new
colon for somebody outside of the body.
I read this,
this thing on their ted.com this
woman had a completely ulcerated large
intestine, so they took some
sort of tissue, CARF culture,
whatever the fuck that means
out of her of diseased colon.
Use that to then grow another one
outside of a body where they would done
growing it.
They took the old one out and put the
new one in like she went down to midas
muffler and it totally
fucking worked okay.
Up until like five years ago,
you will looking at a colostomy bag,
you would have a bag of shit right under
her fucking right titty for the rest of
her goddamn life. Her social
life would have been over. Okay.
If they can do that,
you're telling me you're still going to
tell me they can't do any better than
about 40 fucking 45 miles a gallon.
You're really going to sit there and
believe that in your Goddamn cubicle that
they just can't fucking,
just can't fucking figure it out.
The only way I can get like a hundred
miles a gallon is if I ride on a fucking
scooter. You sir, believe in Santa Claus.
Yeah.
I remember one time I have this
old piece of shit truck, right?
That I drove for like 10 years because
I knew I wanted to be a comedian and I
didn't want to go into debt.
So when the engine finally died,
I threw a new engine in there and the
guy told me he needed to rebuild the
carburetor.
I'm like,
you don't need to rebuild the carburetor
so you know what this cunt did.
He fucking adjusted the carburetors.
So I would just get shitty gas mileage
hoping I would be an absolute fucking
moron and then drive back and be like,
Whoa, I guess you're right. I'm just,
I'm just chowing through gas here.
That's what this mother fucker did.
Okay.
At his little garage.
This little piece of shit did that because
it wasn't enough that he fucking made
1600 fucking bucks off me.
He wanted to make like fucking 1900 bucks.
So he did that just as
a fucking individual.
And you're going to try and tell me that
a corporation that basically controls
the world fucking energy.
He's not going to buy up patents
by people that, that are,
that are, that are are,
are making or coming up with a
carburetors and stuff like carburetors.
But both coming up with,
with,
with alternate ways of powering
a car more efficiently.
They're not going to buy that up. Do
they have that whole Stanley mayor thing?
And that's not a conspiracy theory either.
We actually,
we actually played the news clip
on the opie and Anthony Show.
Stanley mayor,
great news for individuals,
but bad news for oil companies claims
he's come up with an engine that can run
on any type of water,
fresh water, salt water,
rainwater doesn't make a difference in
he claims he can drive across the country
on 28 gallons of water. Um,
this is of such interest.
The Pentagon is sending a
lieutenant colonel out there.
That was the actual news clip
from the opiate Anthony show.
It was an actual news clip.
It's not some bullshit I read
on a fucking website. Okay.
Now what happened after that? Nobody
knows. But basically within 10 years,
Stanley was dead in his car disappeared.
And his brother right now is trying to
get the car back and nobody knows where
the fuck it is. All right? Um, I,
I truly believe that the quickest death
sentence you could possibly have is to
go on the news and claim that you've come
out with an alternate source of energy
that's going to put a corporation
out of business that is making,
that is projected to make
$350 billion next year.
How much do you think your life is worth?
And if you have $350 billion,
how easy is it do you think,
to get somebody to solve this problem?